la la la you ready big guy
yeah I'm like totally ready everyone in
the city gets a shot at being a storm in
our singing competition this thanks is
about to explode with major piggy power
your home see your really funny looking
that's alright cuz I get things cooking
color lady come come my lady you're a
butterfly
baby oh my gosh look at her butt oh my
gosh look at her are you okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you how are you if
you want to become stars and win a
hundred grand and you better be ready to
work harder than you've ever worked in
your lives
oh yes that was dearie bed we're strong
there's no Hill where were you I was a
rehearsal dad I don't want to be in your
gang I want to be a singer how did I end
up with a son like you
music and all the moves and talk to you
get so scared come on be confident don't
you want this I'm back what is going on
here moment wanna freeze it only squeeze
it in Holmby we completed Eve man go
don't let fear stop you from doing the
thing you love you know what's great
about hitting rock bottom there's only
one way left to go and that
[Music]
this my son
she's not even that good yeah yeah
totally just see
I'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
why aren't you rehearsing I'm through
they said I'm an intolerable egomaniac I
don't even know what that means
[Music]
and cue the crazy old lizard a good
morning mr. moon I got Judith from the
bank on line two
actually I'm gonna have to call her back
my theaters been going through some
pretty rough times so what do I do a car
wash no my next show is gonna be
drumroll please a singing competition
who wants to see another one of those
everyone your neighbor the the grocery
store manager that that that chicken
right there real talent from real life
that's what audience is one and I'm
gonna get a tool do you ever feel feel
so paper hi mommy
Merman would you please tell them what a
good singer I am oh yeah you were great
honey by the way the bathroom sink is
blocked again bye honey
in your mind could you ever be really
close to me
[Applause]
you were supposed to be keeping a
lookout sorry dad happy birthday to you
if I had a voice like Mina's I'd be a
superstar by now just singing oh yeah
sure he wouldn't grandmother now blow
out your candles hmm how we doing those
flyers miss Crawley
this will be the biggest hit show this
city has ever seen everyone gets a shot
at being a store live on my stage Amil
win that prize
it's my bra your home see you're really
funny look in that's alright cuz I get
[Music]
oh my gosh look at her butt oh my gosh
look at her are you okay oh yes I'm fine
thank you how are you this is it folks
you better be ready to work harder than
you've ever worked in your lives
yes that was dearie bed got some shows a
file to cite the fire went out a long
time ago you are not gonna believe what
I did today Bob I don't want to be in
your gang won't be a singer how did I
end up with a son aren't you
you just got it now
this show is not gonna save your theater
maybe it's time to move on you know how
much this means to us just
Sanctus about to explode with major
piggy power
[Music]
you know what's great about hitting rock
bottom there's only one way left to go
and that's
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
DiBiase
just bleeding in Aisle 6 that was
awesome
if I feel that I could be sudden when I
would say the things I want to say - he
was supposed to be capable care sorry
dad
my theaters been going through some
pretty rough times lately so what do I
do
quit no my next show is gonna be
drumroll please a singing competition
adjusting your neighbor the the grocery
store manager that that chicken right
there real talent from real life Merman
would you please tell them what a good
singer I am oh yeah you were great honey
by the way the bathroom sink is blocked
again I'm here win that prize it's mine
everyone in the city gets a shot at
being a star on my stage come my lady
you're my butterfly sugar
like the wheel ride like oh my gosh look
at her butt you okay oh yes I'm fine
thank you how are you people say you're
Humpty you're really funny looking
Wow this show is not gonna save your
theater maybe it's time to just move on
come on you know how much this means to
us
you can't just sing it you got two shows
a file and desire the fire went out a
long time ago you are not gonna believe
what I did today I am lost I am bad I
just don't want to be in the gang I want
to be a singer joy I end up with a son
are you gay you are nine wait okay the
money I promised I could really use some
extra piano lessons yes that was very
bad a defining moment in all of our
lives we're going to be spicy no yeah
[Music]
don't let fear stop you've been doing
the thing you love you know what's great
about hitting rock bottom
only one way left to go and that sing
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
the Vig
lady in Aisle 6 awesome
[Applause]
how we do with those fliers miss cross
[Music]
hi Gayle by Maury by Mickey by Moe by
Nelson by Hannah bite a spy by Casper
hey hi what do you think
[Music]
a singing competition just think your
neighbor the the grocery store manager
that that's that chicken right there
everyone in the city gets a shot at
being a store live on my stage rum and
cola lady come come my lady you're my
butterfly
[Music]
my gosh it hurt but oh my gosh
like we're rather cool okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you how are you
[Music]
you